[Music]
i tried to fight it
i tried to tell myself i wasn't going to
do a spider-verse video because i'm not
just a spider-man channel
but stan dammit i have something to say
and i have a feeling no one else is
going to do a video about this
spider-man into the spider-verse made
miles morales
not suck it either changed or threw out
everything bennis did with his
characterization
then added a lot of new stuff to finally
make him feel unique
it was kind of an accident and i don't
think they made these changes because
they didn't like miles
i think they made them out of necessity
and that they fixed a broken character
that was just an empty void of charisma
spider-verse made miles interesting for
the first time
ever as i said in a previous video miles
morales has very few distinguishing
traits that separate him from peter
beyond the superficial
his personality morals and
characterization are either too similar
to peter's
or just muddled and undercooked when
they're more of his own
he's a character that's placed squarely
in spider-man's shadow but his character
arc has never been to step
out of it it's just been to fill the
same space
begging the question of why we need
miles at all if he isn't special beyond
his appearance
with that said some of the more
memorable and unique things about miles
are his supporting cast and his
environment
he has a young and active set of parents
who can be more directly involved with
his social life
he goes to a school for intellectually
gifted students and he has a comic
relief best friend that knows his
superhero secret and supports him
these are the very few bits of
creativity in any of bendis original run
on miles
while he ultimately didn't do anything
with these ideas
these ideas did have potential to give
miles some new kinds of situations to
encounter
that peter hadn't and then the mcu comes
along and steals
all of it to give to peter we wouldn't
have gotten this vision of miles if it
weren't for mcu peter so let's talk
about that for a little bit
by this point we had seen two
live-action spidey adaptations that
borrowed heavily from the ultimate
comics for his origin
making peter and harry childhood friends
making ozcorp the originator of the
spider
and having peter yell at uncle ben
before his demise which amplifies
peter's guilt
the state of spider-man franchise left
the creators at the mcu in a complicated
position
one we already [ __ ] know spider-man's
origin story just don't do it again
that'll be boring
we've seen two peter parkers that live
in a house in queens and date a cute
girl
they both fight mad scientists and harry
osborn after he's had a meltdown
they both mourn uncle ben and test out
their powers make their own suit and
yada yada
at this point we didn't need to see a
third draft of these scenes and ideas
they had to do something different new
they had to rebuild spidey from the
ground up and were falling all over
themselves trying to do it in a short
amount of time
the deal between marvel and sony was
such an 11th hour thing
that marvel studios was prepared to
release a cut of civil war with him not
even in it
then they had to rush tom holland onto
the set and add to him at the
very last minute 2. bendis the idea
machine had already been used twice with
relative ease
his ideas on spidey lend themselves to a
modern take very well
every time a new spider-man movie comes
out the producers will tell you
while we're taking a different direction
with this one we'll be basing it more
off the ultimate comics
this time even though they've done it
every time
lee and ditko spider-man has been left
largely unadapted
save for a few scenes in the rainy
trilogy and the occasional visual
reference and the other stuff
and will probably stay that way forever
for some reason
ideas from 616 continuity only start
getting mostly incorporated from around
or
after the time gwen stacy gets killed
off
marvel producers wanted a fresh new take
and bendis comics have a history of
working out
so they turned to pages of miles for new
ideas
of which there was only a handful but it
was enough to use as a springboard for
a new and different take on pierre
because god forbid the eight
screenwriters just come up with a new
direction on their own without having to
rely on baldylocks for the millionth
time
3. despite what a lot of outspoken fans
from around the time wanted
miles could not become the default in
first spider-man of the mcu
i won't rule out the possibility that he
can show up later but sony specifically
has contracts that say spider-man has to
be a straight white guy
keep in mind this is from the film
studio and not stan lee so if you're one
of those idiots who thought andrew
garfield got fired by stan
for suggesting mary jane be a black guy
you can bury your head into more
paranoia and engineered outrage i guess
but a wider audience really couldn't
accept miles just outright replacing
peter with no explanation
moviegoers are too attached to the
original spider-man it's like if the dc
extended universe started and batman was
azrael
and was just running around killing
people but peter isn't as expendable as
bendis would lead you to believe
all of these factors led mcu peter
parker to essentially just being miles
which is a clone of peter parker with
less attitude and wit and more
clumsy and bumbling while everyone tells
him what to do
now he has a young and active parent he
goes to a school for gifted minds
and ned leeds is a very thinly veiled
reincorporation of genki
plus he has all these avengers he looks
up to and desires to impress
miles wanted to prove that he could be a
real superhero to them and live up to
peter's name
now peter wants to prove he's a real
superhero and like
live up to being the comic version of
spider-man i guess
peter was never really comfortable on a
team setting he accidentally beat up all
the x-men and the avengers treated him
like he was an annoying [ __ ] rather
than an
impressionable kid he's more of this
lone wolf who was able to do team-ups
but found himself operating better
outside of them this whole
characterization feels pulled from miles
miles was a weak character to begin with
but now all he had going for him was
poached and worked into reinventing
peter
side note i now think i've finally fully
articulated why i always roll
my eyes when someone says tom holland is
the most comic accurate spider-man
he's not accurate to the 616 version and
he's certainly not accurate to the
ultimate version either
because that guy was a moody edgy angsty
teen who yelled at everyone and was
prone to violence instead of thinking
things through
tom holland doesn't come across as an
angry hothead and i seriously can't
envision a scene where his version of
peter parker
loses his temper and just starts ripping
on someone's character flaws to hurt
their feelings
before seguing and how much he hates his
own life mcu peter is accurate to the
ultimate comics
circa 2011 this is all a blessing in
disguise
because it forced creators of into the
spider-verse by their own admission
to start thinking of new ways to
characterize miles and his story they
had to cut back on stuff like genki and
had to look at things from a new angle
they were put into the unenviable
position of having to give this piece of
bread in a spider-man suit a personality
well it goes without saying that they
made miles a little more confident when
he feels like he's in his element
he's social and outgoing he values the
community and culture of being a kid
from brooklyn
in the comic he doesn't really have an
opinion on where he lives but his
parents act like he's escaping poverty
when he wins the drawing to go to the
fancy smart people school
it's just one of those lazy examples of
bendis telling instead of showing
we don't see miles going to a public
school being a bad thing
or how his life benefits any differently
from leaving it we don't see brooklyn
being any different from any other
neighborhood in new york
so there's not really any significance
to this spider-verse makes brooklyn feel
like a character in its own right
the people the scenery the style are
also vivid and memorable that you can
understand why miles likes being here
and feel safe here movie miles is now a
fish out of water in his new school at
visions academy
not because he isn't smart but because
he just doesn't relate to any of the
kids here
when the hell did peter have to deal
with a conflict like that it's the exact
opposite of being the only super smart
kid it's being one of hundreds of smart
kids and wanting to feel more like an
individual
miles also deals with heavy expectations
from his parents
and they're not subtle about that part
they want him to be gifted and special
according to their standards instead of
his own
jefferson pushes him to reject his
culture and upbringing in favor of his
education
but after a while realizes that being
smart isn't what makes miles special
it's his passion and his creativity his
adventurous love for creating art and
leaving his mark on the world
what's the conflict between miles and
his parents in the original story well
they um
he uh they're strict
they don't want him to hang out with his
uncle because his uncle is a dangerous
psychopathic criminal
and his uncle is a dangerous psychopath
a criminal so i guess they're pretty
right about that
uh i guess you can't talk about the
changes to miles without acknowledging
the changes to aaron davis
all right i think bendis absolutely
fudged
every single aspect of this character's
inclusion in his original run
and bungled so many potential story
threads and character motivations and
emotional moments
that it's incomprehensible what goal he
was aiming for with the way he wrote
this
for one having both jefferson and aaron
do something weird and abnormal
one becoming a shield agent the other
becoming a high-tech cat burglar
really ruins the idea that miles is just
a normal average kid
it's the same as having peter's parents
be cia agents
we know how well that worked out
rebooting jeff as just a run-of-the-mill
police officer really helps to stabilize
that element
and enforce the fact that it was two
brothers who went down different paths
in life
one became a cop and the other became a
criminal not
one became a secret agent for an
organization with flying boats
after that aaron being a cool fun uncle
is about right at the start
he's not a bad guy at the start and lets
miles just relax and not have to live up
to any rigid standards
although in the comic miles likes
hanging out with him because it's fun
and he lets him have ice cream and watch
movies
in the movie version miles feels like
aaron fosters and encourages his
creativity and allows him to pursue
things that make him happy
one of them just has a better thematic
function where he really diverges how
aaron treats miles after discovering he
has
powers in the comics aaron immediately
tries to capitalize on it and use miles
to get ahead
even beats on him a little to encourage
him to act more like a thug
and then blackmails him it's played like
aaron is trying to seduce him with the
dark side
but at no point does he really let miles
benefit from being a jerk
he just throws him into dangerous
situations where he's scared and having
a horrible time and getting his ass
kicked
so of course there's zero conflict when
miles is faced with the choice of being
a good guy or a bad guy
then he fights his uncle and they get
into an accident that results in aaron
dying
and with his last breath he just says
something shitty and cruel
yeah i bet any of us will be real choked
up about losing this beloved relative
so because aaron is a jerk miles doesn't
really take anything he says to heart
and then after like two issues doesn't
really even think about it ever again
until this poorly thought out
resurrection and his death was really
just a flat out accident that resulted
mostly from aaron trying to fight miles
it's not exactly miles fault that this
happened even if aaron goes out like a
[ __ ] trying to make him think it was
ugh let's catch up with the movie
version aaron only fights miles because
he doesn't know who he is under the mask
he's just following orders to act as an
enforcer for kingpin
but the second he realizes it's his
beloved nephew he has to fight
he has a major change of heart he's
faced with just about the only person he
can't look in the eye and hurt
no matter what money or advantages come
of it he lets miles go
resulting in kingpin killing him miles
takes aaron to a safe place to have a
final moment with his uncle
where aaron regrets the life he chose
and encourages miles to stay a hero and
pursue his dreams
he affirms to miles that doing the right
thing even when it gets you hurt
is the way to go his final words to
miles motivate and inspire him
miles also feels partially responsible
for his uncle's death
because aaron essentially sacrificed
himself to protect miles
miles has to live with the guilt that
aaron placed his life above his own
and paid the ultimate price when i said
miles needed his own uncle ben i didn't
mean that he needed to be more like
peter i meant that
he needed a concrete tangible reason to
become a hero
every good protagonist has an uncle ben
moment
be it batman's parents luke skywalker's
mentor obi-wan
the punisher's wife and kids or that
little girl who died in a car accident
in irobot and made will smith racist
against robots
they need an inciting incident that
pushes them to be whoever they're going
to be as a character
whether they use their grief to become
vengeful responsible
distrustful or guilty they need
something to establish their motivations
it doesn't always have to be a death of
another character
but these can often be the most
effective motivators in origin stories
an uncle ben moment can be as simple as
a character's life changing from a
cancer diagnosis
character like walter white realizes he
wasted most of his life being the
world's [ __ ]
and decides to use his final years for
something cruel and spiteful in response
which he disguises as a desire to help
his family
no one even had to die for this moment
it was just the threat of death but we
get why the character is doing what
they're doing and we can get behind that
we can understand it in the comics miles
gets to peter parker's last stand
relatively at the end of it and just
watches the aftermath
he can't directly intervene because it's
already over
peter is dead before he gets there so
there's no guilt away on him
i said in my original video that i would
have preferred if he showed up like
halfway through this fight and even
considers using his powers to give
spidey some much-needed backup
but backs down from the fear of getting
hurt this is exactly what happens in
spider-verse
miles outright states that he can't let
peter die
twice and he feels obligated to protect
him when given a second chance to help
out
and his uncle's death really sells him
that using your gifts for evil won't get
him
anywhere but more pain and suffering for
the people he loves
aaron being a criminal damaged his
relationship with miles father
and jefferson even tells miles that he's
afraid of them drifting apart the same
way
all it took was a slight adjustment to
the context and now both of these deaths
have
infinitely way more emotional weight and
importance for miles
we now have a version of miles with a
well-stated motivation
conflict in his personal life that peter
didn't deal with
and best of all character agency miles
becomes spider-man because he feels it's
his responsibility
and he learns that he doesn't have to
just copy everything peter did
in fact things seem to go smoothest for
them when peter says
stop listening to me and miles starts
learning to do it on his own
my favorite line from the trailer is
don't do it like me
do it like you and that never appears in
the film
but it's pretty much the main point of
the story
anyone can be behind the mask not just
people who are identical to peter parker
miles succeeds as spider-man by just
being himself
even his costume reflects that the comic
version contradicts and undermines this
point
by having miles always worrying about
copying peter
and living up to him i can't express how
much i love spider-verse in general
it's my favorite animated film to come
out since i was a kid
and it reinvigorated my love for this
character after feeling really
beaten down and jaded by his fandom it's
2018 and you can still make a
really good spider-man movie not only
does it finally allow miles to become
the character he was always meant to be
but it also shows us that there's always
going to be room for peter parker too
and the classic isn't going anywhere
miles morales has been a very mixed
character for me because i appreciate
what he's meant to symbolize and the
insane amount of potential he has but i
always felt bogged down and annoyed by
how little that potential was fulfilled
he was held back because unfortunately
the guy who created him had no idea how
to write him in a way that was
satisfying
i fully believe that as bendis kept
writing this book into the ground with
repetitive and uncreative arcs
miles would have been forgotten by
history like that time captain america
was replaced by an impersonator named
the us agent
at that time deadpool died and was
replaced by a guy named agent x who had
the same sense of humor what was more
sociable
this [ __ ] happens all the time in comics
ideas don't stick legacy characters are
forgotten the status quo is restored
and it all becomes an obscure did you
know fact on a trivia game
20 years later under bendis's writing
miles would have ended up
this same way forgotten
spider-verse may not have sought out to
reinvent him out of spite for the source
material
but out of necessity through a lot of
happy accidents
i think that made for a much more
interesting character who will have
staying power this is the miles morales
i can see my grandkids buying action
figures of
like he's been there from the start so
let's give credit where it's due
bendis came up with the initial spark
but lord miller as well as the whole
crew of the film
crafted something much greater to put it
simply
this kid taught us that anyone can wear
the mask but this kid
came along and proved it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you